all right when i say moline i can i have
a sibling in months congrats man that's
big when i was sibling i probably
i haven't seen lean since my birthday
last year so it's probably about to be a
year
that's big man yeah hell yeah um that
[ __ ] really slowed you the [ __ ] down and
then besides it's slowing you down what
it's doing to your body you're just
taking years off your life like with
anything any vice you feel me alcohol
all that so the whole quarantine i was i
was being healthy mentally
uh physically everything so i feel like
my head got clear and that's what helped
me do this album and be in this
good space i'm in right now so yeah for
so anyone watching this right now man
stay off the lean man
stay off everything as much as you can
man it's cool just smoke some of his
weeds his weed is good
go get that exotic
anxiety yeah otx yeah only the exclusive
did you have a like a low point with
with the lean [ __ ] like a scary scary
situation that maybe made you rethink
whether or not you wanted to [ __ ] with
that no not with lean it's just like
everything i feel like
drinking lean pills partying everything
it's just like that should get
depressing
like you can't be doing it all the time
it just slow you down like and me since
i am a businessman i have so much [ __ ]
to do i can't i'm like yo i can't just
be high